ce théâtre de barcelone n'est pas le
plus grand de la ville mais ici trois
pièces son talent affiche ce jeudi
presque comme avant
sur décision des pouvoirs publics à
talant le lieu peut ouvrir sous
certaines conditions
masque obligatoire distanciation entre
les groupes de spectateurs et surtout
désinfection de la salle assuré ce soir
par le maître des lieux
[Musique]
nous avons mis en place tout ce que les
normes nous impose
nous avons des tapis du traité à
l'hypochlorite de sodium pour que les
chaussures quand elle passe sur ce tas
qui s'imprègne et arrive dans la salle
son virus les spectateurs ne peuvent pas
se croiser il arrive par l'entrée
principale et partent par la sortie de
secours et les deux donnent directement
sur la rue la plus grands contrainte une
jauge maximale de fréquentation fixé à
50% de la capacité du théâtre malgré
tout les spectateurs sont au rendez vous
la distanciation entre la personne est
bien respectée il ne devrait donc y
avoir aucun problème qu'elles ont pris
toutes les mesures nécessaires cozzatti
des et pour moi les lieux culturels sont
sécurisés sinon ils ne seraient pas
ouverts qui maintiennent bien les
distances je suis déjà venu plusieurs
fois et je me sens en sécurité
en plus c'est si nécessaire pour notre
bien-être général et la dernière faveur
accordée aux spectateurs ils peuvent
rentrer chez eux une heure après la fin
du couvre-feu sur présentation de leur
ticket